What’s good mah well read ballas? This week
we bootin’ up and bangin’ out with Fight
Club by Chuck Palahniuk. Our nameless narrator’s
life has taken some weird-ass turns. Right
now he sittin on top a building that’s rigged
to blow any second and his “homie” Tyler
Durden got a piece in our boy’s mouth. How
did things get so f*cked? Well he bout to
tell us in a FLASHBLACK PLAYA!
Da narrator ain’t slept fo’ a longass
time. Da only thing dat get him right is droppin
in on support groups for diseases he ain’t
even got, and weepin’ like he bout to drop
dead. Brutha catchin hella Z’s til he notice
someone new at his nut-cancer meeting- some
GIRL named Marla. Huh? Dat ain’t right.
She showin’ her face at other groups too
and since she eyeballin him like she know
he fakin’, brutha can’t sleep no mo.
So when he call her out on her bullshit, she
like “boy I will narc on yo ass fo’ frontin’
like you sick” So they agree to split up
da meetings. One day da narrator on a bidness
trip when he decide to roll by a nude beach
so he can peep game at some tittays. While
there, he become boys wit some suave-ass philosophical playa named Tyler Durden. Dude headin’ back
to his crib when “OH HAELL NAW.” His apartment
straight BLOWN UP. Not knowin’ what else
to do, da narrator hit up Tyler for a place
to crash. They meet up at a bar and Tyler
say he can stay wit him if he do one thing-
hit him as hard as he can. Say what?
The narrator oblige a brutha, and afta’
dat, they just can’t STOP whoopin on eachotha
just fo da hell of it. Next thing you know,
Tyler and da narrator round up all da dudes
society has beaten down and start a Fight
Club, where they beat on eachother like it
ain’t thang. Our boys move in together at
some run-down shit hole on Paper Street. Soon
Marla start droppin by to do da buck nasty
with Tyler. OOO WEEE!
Da narrator seem mad jealous- ‘specially
since he been havin’ dreams of givin’
it to her good, and cuz Marla hoggin’ all
Tyler’s time.. Afta’ da narrator get tossed
outta work fo the day since he got blood all
up on his threadz, Tyler decide he gonna teach
da narrator a lesson bout what it means to
hit rock bottom. So he whip out some lye and
give da narrator a burn on his hand dat sting
like a BITCH. All da while, Tyler like “stop
trippin’ baby. This is the greatest moment
of yo life and you missin it!”
Since Fight Club need a solid cashflow, da
boys start makin soap using fat sucked outta
Marla’s own MAMA and then sellin’ it to
rich folk! NASTY! As time go by, Fight Club
start blowin UP! They got so many hoods in
they crew, Tyler decide to step up his game
with Project Mayhem, where he take erryday
working hustlas and break em down til they
stone cold gangstas tryna’ stick it to society-
I’m talkin bustin up public property, boostin’
shit, and even piss in people’s grub. Soon
da crib full of so much soap and so many dudes,
not even da narrator know what’s goin on’.
Turns out Fight Club’s goin global now.
Erry time da narrator travel to anotha’
city, people act like they know him and treat
him like some kinda God. Not knowing what
da hell Tyler up to, he call Marla and she
like “What you want Tyler?” “Yo hold
up. What you say my name is?” “F*cking
duh, man. Tyler Durden.” That’s right-
the narrator IS Tyler Durden- like two minds
occupying da same body at different times.
Da hell?
Afta’ his support group homie big titty
Bob gets ghosted doin some project mayhem
shit, he try to tell erryone to put the hustle
aside and just GO HOME. But there ain’t
no stoppin deez gangstas. They in WAY too DEEP!
So they kick da narrator out and now he only
got once choice: he gotta put Tyler DOWN befo’
Project Mayhem completely destroy society.
Now we back where we started- at the top of
a building with a piece in da narrator’s
mouth- cept now we know fool doin it to himself.
Marla and da whole support group gang show
up to help but da narrator like “Hold up...
if Tyler is just in my head then da only way
to kill him is...” BANG- he put one in his
cheek.
Cept, brutha ain’t dead. He wake up in da
hospital where da cats workin’ on him look
a lot like dem project mayhem dudes. They
whisper “We still playin’ on, playa.”
Even though Tyler might be dead, Project Mayhem
sho as hell ain’t.
So... deez dudes are whoopin on each other even
though there ain’t got no beef? What da hell
are they smoking on? Well when you livin’ a
life where yo erry day is grindin’ away
at a desk, wearin’ a suit, sayin’ yes
sir no sir, and actin how you told to act-
how else you gonna know you a legit MAN?
Dats why dem hoods join up with Fight Club-
cuz all da bullshit expectations of “civilized”
society actin like a vice on their nuts. In
a time of pedicures, political correctness,
and sensitivity training , men ain’t men-
they men in captivity. Like Tyler say: “we’re
a generation of men raised by women.”
One dude LITERALLY lost his nuts- da narrtor’s
homeboy Big titty Bob. Bob perfectly representin’
dat emasculation theme. First- da testicular
cancer group is called “Remaining Men Together.”
And second- Bob used to be a swole-ashell
body builder, but afta’ joosin’ too hard,
he a nutless crying bitch with a sweet pair
o’ tittays- which exactly how da men in
dis book feel.
Anotha thing bruthas do to feel like they
top dawg is buy a lot of stupid-ass stuff-
couches, drapes, lamps n’ all dat mess.
But no matta’ how much cash they throw around,
no matta’ how many threadz their sheets
got, it don’t make em feel right, it make
em feel numb. Da only way they can feel ANYTHING
is by literally WRECKIN’ EACHOTHER’S SHIT.
Da narrator say it best: “You aren’t alive
anywhere like you’re alive at fight club (51).”
Dis rebirth all thanks to one of
da realest gangstas in all the lit game: Tyler
Durden. Matta’ fact, Tyler’s leadership
is straight Jesus-like. When Da narrator hit
up Tyler on da phone, his thoughts are a Tyler
re-mix of the Lord’s prayer:
Cept, Tyler is breakin
homies down wit chemical burns and makin’
em obey him like they dogs. And whereas Jesus
tried to better da world through love and
redemption, Tyler say “FUCK redemption.
Society is beyond saving. We gotta burn all
this shit to da GROUND.”
Yuh dis book make us ask some pretty raw questions
bout our lives: Has society gotten so whack
dat we can’t even recognize ourselves as
human beings no more? Or are we so starved fo’
meaning that we willing to do some terrible
shit just to feel like
we really alive? Hmm..
Yo thanks for kickin it with me today, my
well read ballas. Peace!